>> Will Sentance: Bây giờ chúng ta đã đến các lớp phần cuối cùng và
nguyên mẫu lập trình hướng đối tượng, nhưng đặc biệt tập trung vào
mui xe, một số tính năng mà chúng ta thấy hàng ngày trong JavaScript là gì.
Giống như chuỗi nguyên mẫu này, chúng tôi nghe nói về thuộc tính nguyên mẫu này, chúng tôi thấy trên
Các chức năng của chúng ta, như từ khóa mới này mà chúng ta thấy, như từ khóa lớp này mà chúng ta thấy.
Những điều này thực sự có nghĩa là gì?
Chúng tôi thậm chí không tập trung nhiều vào việc xây dựng mô hình AOP như việc sử dụng
đó như một thấu kính mà từ đó chúng tôi hiểu việc triển khai nó trong JavaScript,
nghĩa là hiểu chuỗi nguyên mẫu.
Đó là một thứ thực sự thanh lịch và đẹp đẽ.
Tôi đang sử dụng thanh lịch một lần nữa không biết nó có nghĩa là gì.
Đó thực sự là một vấn đề, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Được rồi, chúng ta bắt đầu.
Vì vậy, một mô hình cực kỳ phổ biến để cấu trúc mã phức tạp của chúng tôi.
Lập trình hướng đối tượng trong nhiều năm và
nhiều năm là cách mà chúng tôi xử lý việc có 100.000 dòng mã trong một tệp.
Không hẳn là một tệp, một ứng dụng, có một số cấu trúc
nó không chỉ làm cái này, rồi cái này, rồi cái này, rồi cái này và
đây, nhưng một số loại cấu trúc tổ chức.
trong JavaScript, nó phụ thuộc vào chuỗi nguyên mẫu.
Đây là tính năng hậu trường cho phép chúng tôi đạt được một số
mô hình hướng đối tượng trong JavaScript.
Nhưng tôi cũng đang nói một công cụ hấp dẫn theo đúng nghĩa của nó là khá tốt.
Chúng tôi sẽ hiểu sự khác biệt giữa proto và nguyên mẫu.
Chúng ta sẽ thấy lớp mới, từ khóa mới trong lớp.
Ví dụ, chúng tôi có thể hiểu một cách trung thực nhất,
trong cuộc phỏng vấn, nơi một trong những câu hỏi phổ biến nhất đối với một nhà phát triển trung cấp cao cấp
là, từ khóa mới đang làm gì.
Chúng tôi sẽ xây dựng nó từ đầu để hiểu đầy đủ về nó
được phép tự động hóa một số công việc của chúng tôi, nhưng
chúng ta cũng sẽ thấy sức mạnh của các chức năng và phạm vi từ vựng bên trong chúng.
Chúng ta sẽ xem từ khóa này hoạt động như thế nào.
Chúng ta cũng sẽ tìm hiểu về đối tượng Dòng tiêu đề lớn đó,
object.prototype, nơi chúng tôi nhận được tất cả các chức năng được chia sẻ của chúng tôi và tất cả các đối tượng nhận được.
Tất cả sẽ đến, chúng ta sẽ bắt đầu bằng cách tự nhắc nhở mình những gì
thậm chí là cốt lõi của phát triển và chạy mã.
Hai điều chúng tôi ghi nhớ, lưu dữ liệu và chạy mã.
Trong một ứng dụng điển hình, ví dụ:
các trò chơi đố vui, lưu điểm số và
tên người dùng của hai người dùng, có thể 100 người dùng, 1000 người dùng đều chơi cùng một lúc.
Đừng nghĩ rằng bằng cách nhìn thấy trên giao diện người dùng,
như nhìn vào hình ảnh trò chơi đố vui mà đó là dữ liệu được lưu.
Đó là dữ liệu được hiển thị, nó được lưu ở hậu trường trong bộ nhớ của Java.
Đó là cách nó ở đó, vì vậy nó không phải là ma thuật, nó vẫn ở phía sau hậu trường.
Đó chỉ là những điểm ảnh.
Đó là hậu trường của máy tính.
Nửa còn lại chạy qua phát triển ứng dụng hoặc
chạy mã là thực sự chạy mã, các chức năng trên dữ liệu đó.
Ví dụ: chúng tôi có một người dùng muốn sử dụng nó để tăng điểm số cho người dùng
khi họ nhận được một câu hỏi đố đúng.
Đó là nó.
Nhân tiện, tôi không biết làm thế nào chúng ta có hàng trăm nghìn dòng mã và
nó rất phức tạp, bởi vì đó là nó.
Tại sao việc học lại khó như vậy?
Trong một trò chơi đố vui, bạn biết không, tôi cần phải cứu rất nhiều người dùng.
Nhưng không chỉ người dùng, tôi phải tiết kiệm và nhân tiện,
tất cả chúng đều có rất nhiều thuộc tính khác nhau, thông tin về chúng.
Điểm, tên người dùng, hình đại diện, URL hồ sơ, cửa hàng email,
trạng thái, trạng thái cuối cùng của sự tham gia của họ với ứng dụng.
Và đó chỉ là sự khởi đầu, đó chỉ là cách sử dụng.
Mọi người có quản trị viên, chúng tôi có các câu hỏi đố vui mà chúng tôi cần lưu lại.
Chúng tôi có kết quả câu đố.
Chúng tôi có các bảng giải đấu và 1000 phần khác.
Tất cả những thứ này đều có dữ liệu được lưu trữ trong thời gian chạy ứng dụng của chúng tôi trong bộ nhớ và
chức năng được liên kết là mã mà chúng tôi có thể sử dụng để tương tác và
sử dụng dữ liệu đó.
Hoặc hiển thị nó, kết xuất nó, hiển thị nó, thay đổi nó đã cập nhật,
xóa nó bất cứ điều gì cho tất cả ứng dụng là chức năng và
dữ liệu liên quan để chạy trên đó.
Vì vậy, nếu chúng tôi bắt đầu với người dùng, tôi không biết có thể làm tăng điểm số đó.
Nó có thể hiển thị những thứ này nhưng trong 100.000 dòng mã,
nó thực sự phức tạp rất nhanh.
Chức năng ở đâu khi tôi cần?
Tôi đã có người dùng của mình và tôi có dữ liệu đáng yêu về điểm số và tên của họ,
tên người dùng của họ, nhưng tôi muốn cập nhật điểm số.
Nhưng đâu là chức năng cho phép tôi xếp hạng điểm?
Tôi có 100.000 dòng mã, chức năng đó ở đâu?
Không chỉ vậy, chức năng đó chỉ áp dụng cho điểm số của người dùng.
Đừng bắt tôi phải bắt đầu, tôi không biết, hoặc tôi cho rằng nó giống như một sự thay đổi
tên người dùng, hoặc vâng, cập nhật hình ảnh người dùng.
Đừng thử và sử dụng chức năng đó trên các bảng giải đấu của tôi.
Đừng cố gắng sử dụng chức năng đó cho câu hỏi đố vui của tôi.
Vì vậy, tôi không chỉ không biết chức năng ở đâu trong hàng trăm
hàng nghìn dòng mã.
Tôi không biết nó áp dụng cho những bit dữ liệu nào và
đó là những gì làm cho việc viết mã trở nên phức tạp.
Quá nhiều dữ liệu, quá nhiều chức năng và nó chỉ áp dụng cho một số bit nhất định.
Và tìm đúng chức năng và
đảm bảo rằng nó chỉ áp dụng cho đúng bit,
chúng ta cần một số loại cấu trúc tổ chức.
Tôi gọi đó là một chút ở đây, dễ lý giải.
Tôi muốn mã của mình dễ hiểu chuyện gì đang xảy ra.
Nhưng tôi cũng muốn mã của mình dễ dàng thêm các tính năng vào.
Đó là chức năng mới cho bất kỳ dữ liệu nhất định nào, giống như người dùng có
chức năng mới bây giờ họ có thể, tôi không biết, họ có thể đăng nhập bằng Facebook.
Tôi muốn dễ dàng thêm chức năng.
Nhưng tôi không muốn tất cả những điều đó phải trả giá
mã của tôi có hiệu suất hợp lý không hiệu quả vì nó có thể làm như vậy.
Mô hình hướng đối tượng và
thực sự là tất cả các mô hình mã, chúng là tập hợp các nguyên tắc,
chúng là các phương pháp tiếp cận thực tiễn tốt nhất cho phép chúng tôi đạt được ba điều này.
Chúng là một loạt các cách tổ chức mã của chúng ta sẽ cùng nhau
hy vọng đạt được ba mục tiêu này.
Và đó là nội dung của nó, chúng tôi sẽ đạt được cả ba điều này,
bằng cách từ giải pháp đến tiếp theo là theo ý kiến ​​của tôi.
Nhưng vì các nhà phát triển thường đến từ các ngôn ngữ khác,
ý tưởng của họ về những gì dễ lý luận có thể không
một kiểu viết và tổ chức mã riêng của JavaScript.
Vì vậy, giải pháp ba và bốn để đạt được cấu trúc mã của chúng tôi theo cách có thể quản lý được,
chủ yếu sẽ là về các viết tắt
mã làm cho nó trông giống các ngôn ngữ lập trình hơn một chút.
Nói cách khác, dễ lý giải hơn nhưng
thực sự dễ dàng để lập luận, chỉ khi bạn hiểu rõ về nó.